how's it going everyone and welcome to
unexpected arrival yeah yeah all spectra
sorry I get that something like takes
sometimes I have to scream reroute like
route a lot I live here these floating
rocks can I had about them head butt
[ __ ] hello head buddy every day in
school I would have about everyone I was
like what's up bro and I had about head
but I do every I won't like even the
teachers they're like whatever you do
beauty don't that but me and I'm here
but but are you saying about the
unexpected under annex unn unn unn unn X
an unexpected and unexplained uh none
expected arrival and uh um no just me
I don't know they're all having trouble
hanging that out what's going on I'm in
the forest
sup
no we're in a house maybe I can have
about this I mean good work oh let's go
in here okay maybe then I saw him for
screaming so loud I don't mean I don't
mean to kill animals and phones kill
headphones ears
what's new kill ears I guess he can't if
you want to it's a giant Jesus doing
there I'm gonna pump this so hard that's
what she said he said oh oh there was a
scholar coming from there
wow that's pretty pretty cool head but
that bad what are you doing there
someone twist your nipples oh man I hope
no one twist my nipples I'm gonna hold
my like this entire playing through I
guess I can't walk I guess I'm gonna do
what girls do
[Music]
he's naked yes what I mean what that was
awkward
that's just kidding I don't care if he's
naked I mean it helps
the nightmares of my past children my
soul and flames wow that's deep morality
bro I wish I was that deep in you huh
yeah no I don't have a girlfriend
are they having sex again oh yeah
definitely good okay let's see what the
note says it's driving trying to
different between reality and nightmares
well I've been there [ __ ] this for
it's so creepy that's beautiful nice guy
though a lot of them stars all naked
guys everywhere oh [ __ ] don't mess with
teleporting naked guys oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's anything my mom told me
she'd be like pity come here I'm gonna
tell you something important
what is it mommy don't ever mess with
teleporting naked guys [ __ ] worst
scenario ever [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no they're
gonna rape me for sure
what's going on oh they're taking off my
pants no don't think of my pants
no no they're like pat on the back good
job hey what's going on Oh nope nope
like if this was real life for me I was
back nope
I'm coming back in the forest nope but I
guess I guess I have to go in here huh
that's a pretty sweet line bra cast
rocky that's what she said
whatever
uh-oh man nobody nope nope canceled out
jpg' this is no safe haven from
remarried or
what's the matter grinder a murderer
[ __ ] I'm laughing of course oh okay
I want to go out help me oh okay we're
good we're good
I need my lantern and Stefano my kids I
wrote something now I must explore this
of serious counsel farther I should
tread carefully though why why why tell
me
Stefano
what are you doing here really I was
sleeping what do you want
Stefano what are you doing in here I'm
scared ah you're always scared what do
you want I need to get I don't trust you
thank you so much that was awesome Thank
You Stefano
that's okay I get used to it I know you
don't trust them you can trust me though
I'm a bro now do you want to get out of
this castle yes actually I do well go in
that door right there oh there's a door
there
it's like chiffon oh well I'm out of
ideas
okay maybe we need to find a key yeah
nice nice Concepcion Concepcion really I
don't even know what
crowbar I'm Gordon Freeman I'm Gordon
Freeman oh no you're not gonna Freeman
your beard a foe guys okay sorry sorry
sorry stefana
what sorry about dropping you geez you
don't have to stop hogging the fun are
you all right
the follow it's not funny the fun oh
okay okay I'm good I'm good
Hey oh sorry I always punish the fun on
everything so let's try use the crowbar
here I'm a man I have the power
that's not he-man I guess yay all right
baby let's go in here but be careful was
that my ex-girlfriend
Stefani your Mexico oh oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no oh I'll be
careful pity
be careful look naked guys never good
news never good news remember what you
want to old you thought but there's a
small hole in the Fergie
we need to find a key look everywhere
behind you Betty
what ahahahahahaha that's not funny
yeah okay let's go in here Hey good
times good times man I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm serious now though go there oh oh oh
[ __ ] huh okay it's good it's good it's
good he's behind you
I need a hurry back here
[Music]
the battles of others wanna stop it stop
faking my oh it's the father Savannah
Savannah we need hiding Savannah we're
closet closet the closet didn't lock
tomorrow where do I go okay fine here
okay okay camouflage the fun
camouflage mode activate that oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] my wife actually I need you down
here Savannah do you see him
oh [ __ ] I see him oh okay this is suede
I'm out don't make any noise oh the [ __ ]
did I say Stefani I'm sorry it's okay I
don't think they'll find me though it's
good
[ __ ]
is he still there what is he doing is he
making pancakes
let me see yes it's okay he's making
pancakes huh don't make noises did you
leave okay go to your left
that's makes less the finer cakes it's
the final kick Oh best cake ever
no but seriously though where do I go
wait oh wow oh oh nice
hey what's making Stephano cakes okay so
where did we go now oh there's a naked
guy here watch out
I think he wants to be careful meeting
I'm awkwardly close to his ass when I'm
reading this the King sailed to order
don't feel - how do I read sometimes the
king ordered me to seal their eye off
only kept like epic name bro
Quebec has the Kate of the private
quarters even he has locked himself away
in madness I lost the King this alone
it's room I'm - where hate to leave this
all the voices in my head I'll go away I
just cry every night I can't sleep a
minute
the cordoning of my own soul just meters
call I'm running in my own pity maybe
there's still hope for the others Martin
must is clearly over three Evelyn
yo my name I'm up did you have a punk or
Castillo pit fun with remedies mutt why
does everyone in this game called every
give more I play every one is called
marketing deepness yeah a lot really
[ __ ] Reez does Martine nah it's the
phone home you know
now Esther its
let's go huh don't make noises okay
I think it's in here oh it's open now oh
good oh look at this Iron Maiden
I don't trust Iron Maiden so you go
first follow it's good yeah it's good
it's I'm just in this guy scratch so I
don't know you said it was seriously
else worse I [ __ ] hit my leg in the
oh wow EJ's serious business you could
seriously die from that oh man I hate
Iron Maiden's and you said it was a cave
freakin liar Stephano Oh Oh seriously
[ __ ] arts oh my god my god I dropped
you again the second time second time I
dropped the camera whenever there's an
Iron Maiden and the door is closing
well that's [ __ ] splendid skill
Stephano let's go
the key should be in here though
well actually it's shooting but there's
actually this loud stinky [ __ ] great
see I'm pissed stop [ __ ] walking
paradox no I'm not
three cease with a pumpkin Triceratops
and wrecked our weapon as I'm [ __ ]
deaf rock stars mine synthetic wigs made
of an wash